le débat sur les ordonnances à
l'assemblée nationale
finalement les députés communistes ont
décidé de voter la loi autorisant le
gouvernement à légiférer par ordonnance
l'enquète sur l'assassinât bisan
certains oui un suspect interrogé au
portugal un témoin croit avoir vu
plusieurs tireurs avec paul non les
conséquences sur le plan de paix au
proche orient
le mauvais temps en france de gros
dégâts dans la manche et de nombreux
départements sous les eaux et puis dans
quelques heures à hollywood la remise
des oscars aux meilleurs acteurs et
réalisateurs france roche évaluera leur
chance mais là messieurs bonsoir pour la
deuxième fois depuis l'arrivée de la
gauche au pouvoir le gouvernement a donc
demander au parlement l'autorisation de
légiférer par ordonnances autrement dit
d'avoir les mains libres et surtout
d'agir plus rapidement sans passer par
un long débat parlementaire
c'est une procédure qui fut d'ailleurs
souvent contestée par la gauche quand
elle était dans l'opposition et qui n'a
été accepté cet après midi par le parti
communiste kke après mûre réflexion il y
à une heure et demie on apprenait donc
que les députés du pc votre est
finalement cette loi d'habilitation qui
permettra au gouvernement de légiférer
par ordonnances pour prendre les
principales mesures d'un plan qui a dit
jacques delors ne compromet pas les
ambitions du gouvernement
le film de cet après midi avec daniel
brême et jean-louis les scènes le
suspense de l'après midi a commencé à
l'assemblée à 15h dans les couloirs
qu'allait donc faire les communistes
voté avec les socialistes le recours aux
ordonnances ou s'abstenir comme andré
lajoinie en avait menacé le gouvernement
à son arrivée le plus entouré georges
marchais ne répond pas
au gouvernement sur la base un
engagement qui est venu à bout du
terrain d'accord conclu entre le parti
communiste et le parti socialiste
et dans ce cadre là d' iliad une
contradiction entre la lutte pour ses
objectifs l'oeil et le nomic du groupe
glisse dans les pouvoirs toujours claude
estier explicite et pendant ce temps là
le texte de la lettre envoyée par pierre
mauroy aux présidents de groupes
socialiste et communiste
une lettre destinée à ses yeux à aplanir
le différend sur les ordonnances et le
différend sur le prélèvement de 1 % et
il y à là disons 1 annonce un peu
nouvelle c'est la possibilité d'alléger
ce prêt nettement pour les familles les
plus modestes sous la forme d'une décote
ou d'un abattement calculée en fonction
du nombre des enfants à charge
beaucoup d'agitation dans les couloirs
mais une certaine léthargie dans
l'hémicycle même pour écouter le
socialiste christian pierret en appelé à
la cohésion de la majorité
la france ne peut compter que sur ses
propres forces
la majorité ne peut compter que sur
elle-même et sur l'adhésion active des
français puissent la majorité prendre la
mesure de l'enjeu et ne pas s'affaiblir
et affaiblir le pays par ses réticences
internes
le ministre de l'économie des finances
et du budget s'est situé lui sur des
hauteurs beaucoup plus philosophique
ayons foi dans l'avenir at il dit mais
il faudra se battre aux entreprises
doivent se préparer à répondre à une
relance de la demande internationale et
donc à relever le montant de leurs
exportations
elles doivent le faire aussi par
l'investissement qui créent des emplois
en amont et en aval
mais nous devons le faire nous tous et
pas seulement l'état par une politique
plus active de l'emploi et du marché du
travail
que pèse mesdames et messieurs les
députés
la menace de 100000 chômeurs de plus ce
qui n'est que le résultat mécanique une
étude sur la réduction de la demande
intérieure en face des possibilités
énormes et encore non explorées pour
créer des emplois
je le répète avec insistance nous avons
les moyens
un de stabiliser le chômage c'est alors
que le suspense a repris d'intensité
avec la suspension de séance réclamée
par le groupe communiste une suspension
de 30 minutes qui a duré près d'une
heure et qui a semble-t-il permis aux
communistes de prendre acte des
engagements de pierre mauroy
c'est en tenant compte de ses
engagements du gouvernement même s'il
nous apparaissent encore insuffisant
mais qui constitue une réponse positive
à nos propositions et au soutien
qu'elles ont rencontrées chez
travailleurs que nous voterons le projet
de loi autorisant la promulgation d'une
ordonnance en persistant à désapprouver
cette procédure qui ne s'imposait pas
fin du suspense il est 18h30 les
communistes et les socialistes voteront
les ordonnances le rpr par la voix de
michel debré et l'udf par celle de
françois d'aubert ont expliqué qu'ils
s'y opposeraient
dans la plus grande indifférence
si nous avons surtout de montrer le ps
et le pc dans ce débat c'est que
l'attention des observateurs politiques
et est toute entière concentrée sur
l'attitude des députés communistes nous
en parlons tout à l'heure avec paul hama
mais en attendant et pour terminer avec
ce processus parlementaire
essayons de voir avec guy schwartz
comment le gouvernement va mettre très
vite en place ce plan de rigueur car il
faut souvent répété il n'y a pas que le
contrôle des changes sous influence des
communistes quatre grandes modifications
vont être apportées au plan d'austérité
initial du gouvernement
tout d'abord pour ce qui est de l'impôt
supplémentaire de 1 % du revenu
imposable
un abattement sera appliquée selon le
nombre d'enfants à charge aux familles
les plus modestes en particulier les
familles dont les impôts sont
inférieures à 270 francs seront
exonérées de cet impôt supplémentaire
deuxièmement pour ce qui est de
l'emprunt obligatoire égale à 10% du
montant des impôts payés en 1982
les contribuables qui auront subi une
baisse de revenus entre 80 et 82 en
seront dispensés
troisièmement toujours en matière
d'emprunt obligatoires son montant sera
calculé avant imputation de la voir
ce call quatrièmement enfin l'impôt
supplémentaire de 1% pourrait être
appliqué cette fois en 1984 ou revenus
d'intérêts donnant lieu au prélèvement
libératoire de 25 % donc l'attitude des
députés communistes voteront votre ont
pas ils ont finalement voté et bien que
mathématiquement les socialistes n'ai
pas eu besoin de leurs voix et bien leur
comportement était intéressant à suivre
pour la mare effectivement le parti
communiste aura grenier gronder menacer
pour finalement approuvé et les
ricanements qui sur les bancs de
l'opposition ponctué l'intervention
d'andré lajoinie ont pu donner
l'impression que le parti communiste a
été contraint une fois de plus de
soutenir à contrecoeur une politique qui
n'est pas la sienne
petit qu'une impression qu il faut par
netteté nuancé le parti communiste a
fait c'est vrai une concession de taille
en votant pour les ordonnances
mais il faut dire que le gouvernement a
lui aussi fait un geste les enfants
quelques sortes eux un pas l'un vers
l'autre et peut-être avait-il intérêt au
sens politique du terme à agir ainsi le
parti communiste d'abord il aurait pu
s'abstenir cet après midi est accordée
comme on dit un soutien critique mais
c'est une attitude qui aurait troubler
les militants et les électeurs
communistes
comment le parti peut-il impunément se
serait-il demande est rejetée des
mesures que les ministres communistes
approuve en conseil des ministres aux
côtés de françois mitterrand il aurait
été accusé de tenir un double langage et
c'est pour éviter un tel reproche qu'il
a donc décidé d'assumer
solidarité oblige des mesures quelques
fins plus il y allait aussi de l'intérêt
du gouvernement
absolument si le gouvernement n'avait
pas satisfait certaines des
revendications du parti communiste il
aurait pris un risque politique
considérable
le parti de georges marchais est sans
aucun doute la cgt ne faut pas l'oublier
aurait exprimé peut-être encore plus
bruyamment leur hostilité à ces mesures
et de nombreux français qui ont des
revenus modestes et qui s'identifient au
parti communiste aurait été persuadé à
terme
à tort ou à raison que ce plan de
rigueur n'était rigoureux qu'à leur
détriment et qu'il comportait de
nombreuses injustices sociales
or le gouvernement a besoin de
l'adhésion de tous les français et
particulièrement de ce français donc si
vous voulez ce compromis passé entre le
parti communiste et et le gouvernement
illustre donc leur volonté de surmonter
la division au sein de la majorité
parlementaire
le rassemblement des français souhaitée
par françois mitterrand passe d'abord
par le rassemblement de toute la gauche
c'est la nature de l'accord conclu
aujourd'hui entre le parti communiste et
l'hôtel matignon
à 23h10 hervé claude animera un débat
sur ce vote sa gauche jean le lagadec de
l'humanité à sa droite dominique jamet
du quotidien de paris ce matin andré
bergeron avait adressé une lettre à
françois mitterrand pour relevé avec
satisfaction un certain nombre de
modifications apportées par le
gouvernement aux plans mais il a
manifesté également beaucoup d'à et et
u2 dans son courrier en attirant
l'attention du président sur l'état
d'esprit des centaines de milliers de
chômeurs et de pré retraités
à noter encore en politique ce recul de
la gauche dans trois élections
cantonales dans le jura les pyrénées
atlantiques et à rouen
dans ce dernier cas le député socialiste
michel bérégovoy le frère de pierre a
été nettement battu par la candidate udf
et puis cet avis de recherche lancé par
le cds son président pierre méhaignerie
d'en face au public sur france inter a
tracé ainsi les contours du candidat
idéal de son parti pour les
présidentielles il faudrait le punch de
chirac l'intelligence de giscard
l'authenticité de barre alors si vous
avez un nom vous pouvez toujours écrire
aux cds deuxième gros dossier de ce
lundi les suite de l'assassinât hier à
lisbonne 10 sam certain luis dans le
hall de l'hôtel où s'achevait lé congrès
de l'internationale socialiste sur l'anc
est elle-même deux éléments nouveaux un
suspect appréhendé
titulaire d'un passeport marocain et
puis la possibilité d'un complice c'est
ce qui ressort en tout cas du témoignage
d'un membre de la délégation française
jean bernard curial qui était à quelques
mètres du dirigeant noël paix lorsqu'il
a été assassiné et qui attentaient
d'ailleurs en vain un massage cardiaque
je crois qu'il était aux environs de
lorsque
une somme certes à lui accompagné d'un
autre de ses amis est arrivée dans le
hall de l'hôtel
il a discuté avec quelques personnes
ensuite il un s'est arrêté un instant
avec un ambassadeur dans annie et une
autre personne
de chypre et il était sur le point
d'aller prendre un café
lorsque je crois mais à ce moment là je
l'aï dit et je crois qu'un choeur qui
était à quelques mètres derrière lui
s'est approché rapidement de lui lui a
tiré
plusieurs coups par derrière tandis que
il semblerait qu'un autre parce qu'on
n'a pas des affirmations précise là
dessus posté près de la sortie
elle lui viser la deuxième personne qui
accompagne un monsieur certainement
ensuite je crois que la suite vous
connaissez il semble certain louis s'est
écroulé dans une
marre de sang
ils femmes certains oui je crois que
quelqu'un qui me disait toujours une
protection pour quoi faire
si on veut m'abattre en mode a trace les
autorités allemandes ont fait savoir cet
après-midi qu'issam certains oui était
recherché pour meurtre dans leur pays
ils étaient soupçonnés d'avoir organisé
un attentat terroriste qui coûta la vie
à un israélien en 1970 à munich
mais le souvenir que laissera issam
sahraouie sera surtout celui d'un homme
qui depuis longtemps a tenté d'établir
un dialogue avec israël
un témoignage recueilli par patricia
cost celui de la veuve de pierre
mendès-france
il pensait qu'il fallait parler avec les
isréliens et que c'était le seul moyen
que de parler directement avec les
israéliens c'était le seul moyen c'est
pourquoi il a commencé à parler avec des
gens comme le royal qui avance un député
à knesset le général plaide à guérir les
autres produits dialoguer pour arriver
un jour à négocier issam certains oui et
faisait en quelque sorte la navette
entre les gens qu'il souhaitait
rencontrer et arafat et rendez compte
des conversations qu'il avait eues et on
avait le sentiment qu'il souhaitait
tellement qu'on arrive à quelque chose
de positif qu'on finissait par y croire
et qu'à chaque fois qu'on le voyait on
avait le sentiment d'avoir fait un pas
du bon côté
incontestablement la journée d'hier est
à marquer d'une pierre noire dans la
recherche pour la paix au proche orient
coup sur coup en effet deux événements
évidemment lié la disparition d'un
modérait de l'ol paie et puis l'annnonce
de la rupture des négociations
jordano-palestinienne c'est un pan
entier du plan regan qui s'écroule
le président américain ne s'est pas
trompé et soviétiques n'ont plus l'âge
ans tu as parlé tout à l'heure d'un coup
mortel au plan hagan paulin y sommes
certains oui symbolisait le courant
modéré de l'ol paie mais aussi toute
l'ambiguïté de ce mouvement et sa mort
représente un échec pour la tentative de
dialogue qui s'était instaurée
officiellement et officieusement depuis
un an
tout aussi grave l'échec des
négociations entre
afat et le roi hussein de jordanie car
au delà de cet échec c'est tout le plan
regan qui est remise en question ce plan
était la dernière chance pour que les
voix des extrémistes palestiniens et
israéliens ne se refasse pas entendre au
proche orient
et ce n'est pas une coïncidence issam
sahraouis étaient favorables à cette
solution jordano palestinienne sans
oublier que tous les pays occidentaux et
les grands pays arabes comme l'egypte et
l'arabie saoudite appuyer le plan arias
d'ailleurs dès hier soir le chef de
l'exécutif américain a rendu responsable
à ruth la rupture jordano-palestinienne
des éléments extrémistes de l'ol paie le
président reagan a poursuivi la pression
et les changements dias et arafat sont
inacceptables pour le roi hussein de
jordanie et le roi fahd d'arabie
saoudite apparemment donc les durs du
mouvement palestinien ont remporté les
victoires
ceux là même qui au congrès d'alger
préconisé comme seule solution la lutte
armée contre l'état d'israël
yasser arafat pour préserver l'unité de
son organisation a choisi l'ambiguïté
c'est à dire qu'il ne s'est pas prononcé
clairement alger pour ou contre la ligne
modérée
les conséquences sont aujourd'hui
dramatique son principal conseiller a
été assassiné et le gouvernement
israélien aura beau jeu de dire que l'ol
paie a choisi la ligne dure et qu'en
aucun cas on ne peut négocier avec cette
organisation
et pour être tout à fait complet sur ce
dossier sachez que ce matin yasser
arafat a nommé à la place d'issam
sahraouis à nice règne un monsieur lévy
qui travaillent et à l'ol fait depuis
plusieurs mois
une façon pour yasser arafat de montrer
que le dialogue avec les modérés
continue thaïlande deuxième livraison
d'armes américaines en trois jours ce
sont là deux avions de transport géants
qui ont atterri sur l'aéroport de
bangkok
on peut voir le déchargement de 8
obusiers de 155 mm un dernier chargement
est attendu par mer c'est dire si les
thaïlandais ont l'intention de contrer
vigoureusement l'offensive est la mienne
à la frontière mais rod payant
autre conflit la guerre iran irak
téhéran vient d'annoncer que plus de
4500 soldats irakiens avaient été tués
ou blessés au cours de la nouvelle
attaque iranienne
la nuit dernière enfin afghanistan la
résistance a annoncé la mort d'au moins
35 soldats soviétiques lors de l'
attaque surprise d'un poste militaire
près du tunnel de salang dans le nord du
pays pourtant la présence militaire
soviétique est impressionnante
éric durand schmidt a pu le constater à
kaboul et dans ses environs
lors d'un reportage autorisé par le
régime afghan
une colonne de chars soviétiques dans
les rues de kaboul
regardez bien ce temps il est
spécialement équipé pour faire sauter
les mines posées par les résistants des
mines qui ont tué des centaines de
soldats russes
même en ville les canons reste braquée
dans toutes les directions
c'est dire à quel point l'insécurité
écran
ces images prises clandestinement à
l'aéroport de kaboul met en évidence
l'importance de ce qu'on appelle ici le
contingent limité des dizaines de mig
d'hélicoptères de chars de lance
missiles
l'aéroport de kaboul et la principale
base soviétique en territoire afghan
une base où règne une tension extrême
les soldats se font attaquer dès qu'ils
sortent ainsi quand les soviétiques
quittent leur camp c'est pour aller au
front
leur unique supériorité l'aviation les
mig bombarde sans arrêt les montagnes
suivi des hélicoptères mi-24 équipés de
roquettes de 57 mm et de mitrailleuses
de 12,7 des engins qui décapite les
troupes de combattant de la foi
impuissante devant le feu du ciel une
caserne modèle à kaboul
80 soldats par chambre les troupes
afghanes ravagé par la désertion n'ont
pas le moral
ils étaient cent mille soldats à
l'arrivée des soviétiques
ils ne sont plus que 30 milles les
autres ont rejoint la résistance alors
des agents afghan et russe ont recruté
de force des jeunes de 14 à 15 ans pour
aller combattre les moudjahidine une
preuve que le gouvernement n'a pas
l'appui du peuple
les soviétiques ne font plus confiance à
l'armée afghane dont certains éléments
ont tiré sur des officiers
d'autres ont détourné des fusils et des
munitions pour les livrer à la
résistance voilà pourquoi même au cours
de l'entraînement
les soldats afghans sont privés de leurs
kalachnikovs
aujourd'hui ce qui reste de l'armée est
totalement infiltrés par des
informateurs travaillant pour le compte
des moudjahidine
cela contraint les commandants
soviétique a gardé secret leur plan
d'attaqué
jusqu'à la dernière minute
quant à l'équipement il est russe
excepté ces casques apparemment
récupérés sur des soldats allemands
pendant la dernière guerre ainsi
s'entraîne l'armée afghane simulant
d'improbables encerclement en rase
campagne improbable car la guerre se
joue dans les montagnes voilà dans
quelles conditions collaborent les deux
armées selon certaines rumeurs
des troupes ont été déplacées vers
kandahar au sud et dans la province du
bas congo voisine du pakistan la grande
offensive du printemps se prépare
pour asseoir son autorité le
gouvernement a besoin du concours des
chefs tribaux
moyennant finances ils sont venus
écouter le ministre des affaires
tribales qui leur a demandé de soutenir
la révolution communiste
après quoi ils seraient délivrés de la
pauvreté et de l'ignorance
ce chef tribal a eu peur d'être reconnu
à la télévision et d'être traités de
collaborateurs celui ci a été blessé
lors de son retour au village celui là a
été éventrée à coups de poignard
c'est vrai l'enjeu est important sans
les chefs tribaux
rien ne sera possible pour le
gouvernement après trois années
d'occupation
la révolution n'a aucun soutien
populaire et sa survie dépend de plus en
plus de la présence militaire soviétique
à la suite de la diffusion il a beaucoup
impressionné du procès philippot voyais
arrière sur antenne 2 les amitiés franco
afghane la frane tiennent à rappeler que
ceux qui vont porter de l'aide aux
populations afghanes ont une action
d'ordre strictement humanitaires et
démentent formellement avoir le moindre
contact avec quelques services secrets
que ce soit la grève des internes et des
chefs de clinique
le mouvement se durcit à paris comme en
province à sa quatrième semaine
pourtant le secrétaire d'état à la santé
edmond hervé team que la constatation
n'est pas terminée loin de là les
discussions pourraient se prolonger
jusqu'à fin octobre
aujourd'hui pour la première fois le
représentant de l'ensemble des chefs de
service hospitaliers sorti de sa réserve
pour exprimer son inquiétude la
situation est très préoccupante et je ne
dirai même dramatique parfois car une
grève de courte durée on peut définir un
service minimum mais dès qu'elles
dépassent une certaine durée ce qui est
le cas elle devient tout à fait est
préoccupante sur le plan de
l'organisation et du fonctionnement
normal de l'hôpital public
je pense que les pouvoirs publics
actuellement dispose de
moyen de débloquer la situation soit par
des propositions de conciliation soit
éventuellement par des mesures
d'autorité
ja je crains et nous craignons tous que
ce mouvement se durcissent et nous le
déplorons lyon car une fois de plus
ceux-ci aggraverait considérablement le
fonctionnement de l'hôpital public est
essentiellement poserait un problème de
santé pour la population générale
ce commentaire du bulletin quotidien du
parti socialiste en faisant une grève
des soins le médecin prend le mada le
malade en otage c'est d'une gravité
exceptionnelle écrit franck cerrusca le
médiateur alizés robert fabre est venu
remettre son rapport annuel au président
un public en lui proposant un certain
nombre de simplification administrative
robert fabre qui propose que les cours
d'instruction civique soit remise à
l'honneur inauguration aujourd'hui du
salon de la recherche industrielle
innova 83 l'occasion pour laurent fabius
de faire sa première apparition publique
en tant que ministre de l'industrie et
de la recherche
une responsabilité qu'il a ainsi défini
à alain doublé ce qui non sans avoir
auparavant remis en cause ce que l'on
appelle la politique des filières le
septennat précédent avec pour méthodes
de sélectionner seulement certains
créneaux en d'autres termes
regardez ce que les autres nous laisser
faire et sur ces créneaux là pour l'été
performant
ce n'est pas non mais le malheur c'est
ça ne suffit pas du tout pour assurer
l'emploi en france alors à l'autre
extrémité on pourrait dire bien sûr y
ont beaucoup plus volontariste et
construisant l'ensemble de l'industrie
de l'amont à l'aval
et c'est vrai que dans certains secteurs
je pense au bois papier à l'électronique
ça peut être utile mais vous savez moi
je suis pas un homme noble mais les
choses ne sont pas blanches ou noires et
côté pragmatique dont je crois que des
filières sont utiles dans beaucoup de
domaines mais qu'on ne peut pas tout
faire j'avais la grande leçon aussi la
stratégie indicielle française c'est
qu'on ne peut pas tout faire il faut
donc bien choisir les angles d'attaqué
vous avez déclaré je serais mise de
toute industrie alors qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire concrètement que
je suis ministre de l'ensemble des
entreprises les grandes et les moyennes
et les petites et le ministre du secteur
privé et du secteur public
il n'y a aucune exclusive un bon début
de semaine pour la bourse indicateur de
tendance en hausse de plus de 1,5 pour
cent depuis janvier il a monté de 25 %
la sphère du boeing algérien qui part
sans prévenir et qui revient sans crier
gare et bien la présidente du tribunal
d'ivry-sur-seine s'est donné jusqu'à
demain pour débrouiller l'imbroglio et
rendre son jugement
une nouvelle loterie bientôt à la
disposition des français c'est ce qu'a
annoncé le président national de la
confédération des débitants de tabac
cela s'appellera la loterie instantanée
la moitié droite sera un billet de
loterie nationale la moitié gauche
comprendra un cache qu'il suffira de
gratter pour voir apparaître un chiffre
et si celui ci correspond au numéro
porté sur la partie droite est bien le
joueur aura gagné et sera immédiatement
pays autre forme de loterie se disent
les mauvaises langues celle qui va se
dérouler dans moins de cinq heures
maintenant à los angeles
la traditionnelle cérémonie des oscars
france roche supputent les chances de
chacun la palette des votes des membres
de l'académie des arts et techniques
cinématographiques va du rose shocking
ou blanc immaculé qui gagnera le film
contant l'histoire d'un petit monstre
aussi extra terrestres qu'attendrissant
iti qui a déjà fait gagner quelques
milliards à ses producteurs
ouais
et à celle d'un apôtre de la liberté
dans la non-violence gandhi la
reconquête du respect de soi par un
avocat alcoolique verdict ou les
mésaventures d'un homme que le succès
oblige à vivre en gip tutsi pour les
candidats au prix d'interprétation il
yad'autres voyage à travers les séries
julie andrews
il est favori dans victor victoria joue
le rôle d'une femme qui se fait passer
pour un homme qui se déguise en femme
robert preston qui incarne son
imprésario un très charmant garçon
adorant les dames sauf dans sa chambre
est proposé pour le meilleur second rôle
si pour ben kingsley n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté
sa performance est en effet un shader de
virtuosité de pureté d'un gandhi ni pour
paul newman en sommes usés en proie au
doute avec le monde selon garp on
revient aux curiosités john lithgow qui
lie aux palois l'un d'eux m y joua
footballeur est devenu transsexuel
il est candidat au prix du second rôle
lui aussi autres mais c'est de rendre ça
moins douloureux allez enfin cocorico un
film français a une chance sur cinq de
recevoir l'oscar du meilleur film
étranger
ces coups de torchon de bertrand
tavernier on croise les doigts pour lui
jugement rendu demain
même s'ils ne m'appellent pas maman
regard des rats j'espère bien le mauvais
temps maintenant violente tempête dans
la manche plusieurs disparus situation
toujours aussi critique dans plusieurs
régions le poids de 20 la région
parisienne est d'abord l'alsace 2000
tierces de mémoire d'alsaciens on
n'avait jamais vu ça
et ce matin les hélicoptères de la
protection civile constatait encore
qu'aucun village du haut rhin n'avait
été épargné
algolsheim au sud de colmar la digue qui
protégeait cinq villages s'est renversé
les hauts de l'île ont envahi les champs
les routes les maisons plusieurs
centaines d'habitants ont été évacués
sur l'ensemble du département 9000
pompiers sont mobilisés et l'armée est
en pré alerte
le plan orsec a été déclenché seul moyen
de locomotion dans ces cas là la barque
où le tracteur aucune victime ici de ces
inondations
mais pour certains beaucoup d'émotion
moi je suis ni à sermersheim le 4
janvier 1907 et vous avez déjà à
constater des inondations de cet
important non pas de cette importance
encore jamais pensé vous en lorraine
poitou charentes ou loiret les images
sont identiques à celles ci même si la
décrue s'amorce dans la région d'orléans
de nombreuses départementales sont
encore coupées à la circulation et ce
sont près de 2000 personnes qui ont dû
être relogés caves inondées voitures
emportées pylônes électriques arrachés
la décrue permet à présent de réparer
petit à petit les dégâts mais ces
inondations étaient comme les autres
cruel puisque trois personnes y ont
trouvé la mort alors demain alain
gillot-pétré ça ne va pas décroître
surtout au sol
non effectivement il tant que la lame
d'eau qu'aux mondiaux météo n'est pas
passé eh bien il faut attendre qu'elle
aille à la mer pour que ça s'arrange et
cela dit il va quand même pleuvoir
demain mais ce sera un petit répit bien
mouvementée regardez la photo satellite
c'est très clair cette dépression s'en
va mais c'est quand même bien chargé
derrière et donc regarder la carte pour
demain surtout sur la moitié nord les
nuages seront encore abondants avec des
averses les environs au nord à
nord-ouest le baromètre sera en hausse
car un anticyclone viendra mais cela
restera chargé beaucoup moins sur la
moitié sud où les éclaircies seront
prédominante surtout sur le golfe du
lion grâce au mistral quelques averses
de neige sur le nord des alpes et les
pyrénées
un peu plein temps un peu plus chargé
sur la corse et températures seront en
baisse
voyez la flèche minimum 6 degrés maximum
17 degrés baisse de 4 5 6 degrés selon
les régions
on repasse en dessous des normes demain
mardi 12 avril quatre minutes de soleil
en plus lever 7h09 coucher 20h36 et nous
serons mieux à la lingerie traict le
nous retrouverons pour le flash
d'information de midi demain en suisse
12h45 antenne de midi pour ce soir 23h
vi le journal d'hervé claude avec un
débat entre deux journalistes de
sensibilités différentes
jean le lagadec et dominique jamais
passé une très bonne soirée j'aurais
plaisir de vous retrouver demain à 20
heures
à